si vous regarder directement devant vous
josée morin est optométristes et
travailleuses autonomes en 2009
elle achète une assurance en cas de
maladie grave auprès de la great west el
pais 330 $ par mois pour une police 200
mille dollars qui couvre une vingtaine
de maladies comme la cécité les crises
cardiaques ou le cancer en décembre 2016
elle découvre une flaque de sang dans la
cuvette de diagnostic et brutale il
souffre d'un cancer du rein
j'ai un cancer qui risque de me faire
mourir qui ce texte peut me faire mourir
à 30 ou 40 % en l'espace de 5 malgré la
gravité de son cancer l'ablation
complète de son rein droit
sa compagnie d'assurances refusent de
l'indemniser son cancer ne répond pas
aux critères inscrits dans sa police
d'assurance tonnes maladie pour laquelle
je pensais couvert et tu dois dépenser
de l'argent du thym du stress pour faire
valoir quelque chose qui apparaît c'est
un droit acquis c'est inimaginable
la plupart des compagnies d'assurance
offrent différents protection en cas de
maladie grave
on vend le produit en présentant une
liste de maladies couvertes mais voici
ce qui arrive quand on entre dans les
détails présence de carcinome hureaux
des lials in-situ ça c'est la lettre de
refus souhait sacré chez les individus
ce que moi j'appelle un faux sentiment
de sécurité
son avocate crois qu'il était impossible
pour sa cliente de comprendre la portée
de sa police d'assurance
lorsqu'elle a signé son contrat pour un
assuré qui lisse au site chinois à moins
d'être médecin que ce soit que vous
dénoncez exactement un an plus tard
josée morin apprend qu'elle a un
deuxième cancer
mais là encore ce n'est pas assez grave
au sens de ces polices d'assurance le
sentiment terrible d'avoir été floués
dans une période où ta vie est en danger
josé morais a l'intention de poursuivre
sa compagnie d'assurance la great west
refuse de commenter son dossier
il nous a également été impossible
d'obtenir le point de vue de la cap
l'organe
ce qui représente l'industrie ici à new
dance risso radio canada montréal